Do you guys have conversations about trying to shift the public perception of
having this left wing bias,
maybe possibly addressing it?
Yeah,
that's what they're doing right now,
right?
Yeah.
I mean I went on the Sean Hannity Show,
right?
You know,
we,
how was that we brought ourselves before.
It was pretty a lot of sunlight.
It was short and he,
well it was short and um,
the run a lot of really tough questions and that was a feedback as well.
And yeah,
I get it.
Like,
look again,
I'm also,
I'm from Missouri.
My Dad is a Republican.
He listened to Hannity,
he listened to rush Limbaugh.
My mom was a Democrat and I feel extremely fortunate that I was able to first
see that spectrum but also feel safe enough to express my own point of view.
But when I go on some of them like Hannity,
I'm not talking to anybody.
I'm talking to people like my dad who listened to him.
And I want to get across how we think and,
and also that are thinking of all these and here's the challenges we're seeing.
And like,
this is our intent.
This is what we're trying to protect and we're,
we're gonna make some mistakes along the way and we're going to admit to him,
we didn't admit to them in the past week and middle to a lot more,
uh,
over over the past three years.
Um,
but you know,
I don't know any other way to address some of these issues.
It all,
it all goes back to trust.
Like our,
one of our core operating principles is earning trust.
How do we earn more trust?
And I,
you know,
the people in the world who do not trust us at all,
and there are some people who trust us a little bit more,
but this is the thing that we want to measure.
This the thing that we want to get better at.
I saw you get a conversation with I think Katie Hertzog.
No,
no,
no.
Who Was it?
Um,
as the wrong person.
You had a Twitter conversation with Kara Swisher.
Wow.
Wrong person,
but someone's got to shut up.
Uh,
and,
and you know,
I see that the left goes at you in the opposite direction.
They want more,
they want more banding,
they want more restrictions.
And then looked at the right is saying less.
Right.
So I mean in terms of solving the problem,
you uh,
tell us what their conversation was about.
Uh,
I would you want to summarize it cause it,
cause my,
the thing I was pointing out specifically was that you were being asked to do
more in terms of controlling it wasn't just more,
but to be a lot more specific about what
actions we've taken to promote more health on the platform.
Like what products did we change,
what policies did we introduce in the past,
uh,
two years.
Um,
uh,
so she was asking questions.
Every question she asked.
She wanted me to be a lot more specific.
And some of these things have something that is very specific,
some are directional right now because like we,
we have to prioritize,
you know,
the,
the direction.
And,
and I talked about like,
you know,
we've decided that physical safety is going to be a priority for us.
And to us that means like being a whole lot more proactive around things like
doxing.
So
he was a guest means,
I guess I'm not going to imply that you have unlimited funding,
but we did mention the peer review.
Oh,
right,
right.
And you had,
you mentioned earlier with layoffs and retraction,
uh,
peer review,
which we mentioned,
but have you considered opening an office,
even a small one for trust and in an area that's not predominantly blue so that
at least you have like you can have some pushback and what is learned to code
mean and then they could tell you.
Absolutely.
That's it.
That's great feedback.
And just seeing,
you know,
to trust and safety team is also global team and the enforcement team is global
team.
So it's not like people from California who are looking at everything making
decisions there are global.
Now I hear your point about who trains them and the materials they have and all
of that.
And like we have to think about that.
And um,
that's,
that's one thing that Jack has really been pushing us to think about is how do
we decentralize our workforce?
Because out of San Francisco in particular,
so this is something he's very focused on.
What about publishing evidence of wrongdoing and abandon.
So when people say,
you know,
what did Alex Jones really do?
Maybe a lot of people didn't realize what you,
what you saw.
And again,
it's an issue of trust.
Yeah,
I love this,
Tim.
I'm a lawyer.
So by training,
um,
we're thinking of doing something called we call case studies,
but essentially like this is our case law.
This is what we use.
And so high profile cases,
cases,
people ask us about like to actually publish this so that we can go through,
you know,
tweet by tweet just like this.
Because I think a lot of people just don't understand and they don't believe us
when we're saying these things.
So to put that out there so people can see it,
and again,
they may disagree with the calls that we're making,
but we at least want them to see why we're making these calls,
I think.
And that,
that I do want to do,
I want to at least start that by the end of this year.
So I think,
you know,
ultimately my main criticism stands and I don't see a solution to in that
Twitter is an unelected,
unaccountable as far as I'm concerned.
When it comes to public discourse,
you have rules that are very clearly at odds as we discussed.
I don't see a solution to that.
And I think in my opinion we can have this kind of like we've tone things down.
We've had some interesting conversations,
but ultimately,
unless you're willing to allow people to just speak,
speak entirely freely,
you are in,
we have an unelected group with a near monopoly on public discourse in many
capacities.
And I understand it's not everything rented.
It is big too.
And it's,
you know,
what I see is you are going to dictate policy whether you realize it or not and
that's going to terrify people and it's going to make violence happen.
It's going to make things worse.
You know,
the,
I,
I hate bringing up this example on the,
on the rule from mis-gendering because I'm actually,
I understand it and I can agree with it to a certain extent.
Um,
and I've,
you know,
nothing but we're nothing but respect for the trans community.
But I also recognize we've seen an escalation and street violence.
We see a continually a disenfranchised large faction of individual in this
country.
We then see only one of those factions,
band.
We then see a massive multinational billion dollar corporation with private and
Wioa foreign investors.
And it looks to me like if you hold,
if you know,
foreign governments are trying to manipulate us there.
I don't,
I don't see a direct solution to that problem that you do have political views,
you do enforce them.
And that means that Americans who are abiding by American ruler being excised
from political discourse,
and that's the future.
That's it.
We do have views on,
on the approach.
And,
and again,
uh,
we,
we ground this in creating as much opportunity as possible for the largest
number of people.
Right?
That's where it starts
and where we are today,
um,
we'll certainly evolve,
but like that,
that is what we are trying to base our,
uh,
rules and judgment.
It's not,
and I get that.
That's an ideology.
I completely understand it.
But we,
we also have to,
we also have to be free to experiment with solutions and experiment with
evolving policy and putting something out there that might look right at the
time and evolving.
I'm not saying this is it,
but like we,
we look to research,
we look to our experience and data on the platform and,
and we make a call and if we get it wrong,
we're,
we're going to admit it and we're,
we're going to evolve it.
But I guess,
do you,
uh,
do you understand my point?
I understand the point that they are,
there are American citizens abiding by the law who have a right to speak and be
involved in public discourse that you have decided aren't allowed to.
Yeah.
And,
and I think we've discussed,
um,
like we,
we,
we don't see that as a win.
Uh,
we,
we see that as not promoting health ultimately over time.
Right.
But it's ultimately what is your priority?
Do you have it prioritized in terms of what you got w what you guys would like
to change?
I think Jack has said it a couple of times,
but the first thing we're going to do is prioritize people's physical safety
because that's gotta be understanding.
You already have done that pretty much.
Right?
When you do that more,
we've prioritized it.
Okay,
we're,
we're doing the work.
I don't think companies like ours make the link enough online and offline
ramifications.
What's the main criticism?
What's the main criticism you guys,
is it censorship that you guys experience?
Is it censorship?
Is abandoning like what does it,
what does ends?
What do you get the most?
It depends on who.
Every single person has a different criticism,
so I don't think there's a universal opinion.
I mean you're just painted the picture right between the,
the left end of that spectrum is asking for more.
Sure.
The ride is asking for less.
That's very simplified just for this country,
but at a high level.
Yeah,
that's consistent.
I mean,
my opinion would be,
as much as I,
I don't,
I don't like a lot of what people say about me,
what they do.
The rules you've enforced on Twitter have done nothing to stop harassment
towards me or anyone else,
right?
I swear to God my Twitter,
I mean my reddit is probably,
you know,
50 messages from various,
far left and left wing sub.
It's lying about me.
It calling me horrible names.
The quote tweeting me and these people are blocked,
right?
And I never used to block people because I thought it was silly because I can
get around in any way.
But I decided to at one point,
because out of sight,
out of mind,
if they see my tweets last,
they'll probably interact with me last.
But they do this and they lie about what I believe.
They lie about what I stand for and they're trying to destroy everything about
me and they do this to other people.
I recognize that.
So ultimately I say,
well,
what can you do?
It's going to happen.
I'm one of these platforms.
The Internet is a thing,
as they say on the Internet.
Welcome to the Internet.
So you know,
to me,
I see Twitter trying to enforce all these rules to,
to maximize good.
And all you end up doing is stripping people from the platform,
putting them in dark corners of the web where they get worse,
and then you don't actually solve the harassment problem.
Retard the dark corner of the web.
Right,
right.
No,
I'm not talking to him,
but there are dark corners.
I've read it.
There were alternatives.
I mean,
the Internet isn't going to go away and people have found alternative.